okay welcome to another
episode of uh history
of science and technology q a so i'm
happy to talk about
uh both general history of science and
technology and
particular interactions that i've had
in my depressingly long life with
different aspects of that history
so i see there are a bunch of questions
saved up perhaps from last time
it's a question from parmenides i hear
did i ever meet any of the manhattan
project spies
like klaus fuchs etc
well let's see what no i did not meet
them i never met them
um i'm trying to remember a few things
that i know about this
uh i remember once being in moscow
and driving past a house which i was
told
was the house of uh one of these folk
uh just a little bit of history um in
uh after the second world war
the um uh there were a number of
people in the uk particularly who um
uh were
oh i'm sorry that that house was
probably one of the philby crowd
there were there were a number of there
was a there were
well a bunch of spying scandals uh with
the soviet union
and um uh the two two
big clusters in in the uk
and then ones in the us so in in the uk
uh
there were the whole um uh story of
of a bunch of sort of uh people
from cambridge who wound up in the
british intelligence services
um who were i don't know spying on spies
who were spying on spies and it was a
whole big mess
um and uh um eventually they all
uh uh went to live in soviet union for
better or worse
but in in terms of the um
[Music]
the uh scientific side of things the
most
significant uh sort of spying stuff had
to do with
questions about nuclear weapons
technology
and particularly centered around los
alamos
lab um and whether the information about
how
the you know atomic bombs developed in
the manhattan project
did that get to the soviet union how did
it get to the soviet union to what
extent was that based on espionage
and so on and one of the people who was
that sort of the central figure in that
was a person called klaus fuchs
and um i'm trying to remember all of the
history here but but um i can tell you a
few fragments
i mean klaus fuchs worked at los alamos
um and he was i think originally german
and um
then uh um uh
was a theoretical physicist and um
i know dick feynman told me that um
uh klaus fuchs had sort of talked to him
and asked him you know what did he think
about
the communism et cetera et cetera et
cetera
and uh feynman told me that that you
know
years later when it became clear that
the class folks had been
spying for the soviet union he was like
ah now i understand but he said
it was very weird conversation and he
hadn't really you know
given much feedback and it was just an
odd conversation
i think it is one of these things where
where
um now now uh you know the other sort of
fragment here is
is class folks was was then i think
um the head of the theoretical physics
group at harwell
lab in england i worked at a place
called the rutherford lab when i was
a kid that was sort of on the same site
as harwal harwer was the kind of
atomic energy research organization and
rutherford lab was a
particle physics organization um and how
well
at the time when i was there which was
mid 1970s was was still
a little bit there was still all kinds
of all kinds of talk about
you know klaus fuchs you know one day
suddenly he was arrested as a spy and he
was leading their theoretical physics
group and this was big trauma
um somehow i also oh
gosh i'm this is fragments from my
memory but i remember
somebody who who had explained that they
had
shared a a prison cell with klaus fuchs
and he had taught them to play the
violin but i'm trying to remember
who that was and in what context but um
that's another
british memory of some kind but the
answer is i i
you know in my uh when i was sort of
first doing physics um particularly in
the uk there was still sort of echoes of
some of that story
um that existed in the in the mid-1970s
um so that that's uh
it's always a strange thing whenever one
of these scientific um
um uh you know weird scientific spying
things which come up with
different countries at different times
but um sometimes
you know when it turns out that oh that
was what was going on with this person
you you realize you've you've had some
glancing interaction with them and they
were really weird
and it was like really they're
situations in which
when as uh you know people are like
producing this kind of word soup of
descriptions of things that doesn't make
a lot of sense
and i i was uh i'm probably a bad person
to do that with because i
know enough about a bunch of different
things that you know
many pieces of the word soup i can pick
up and it's like this doesn't make sense
it doesn't fit together but it's always
it's always strange to to
to see that kind of you know what is the
linkedin sequence that that um
uh through which you might know some
some some random person who
who turns up in that in that weird uh
in that weird situation but anyway so
the answer is no i did not directly know
any of these people
um oh boy you're asking about people
brandon is asking
did i have interactions with aaron
schwartz the answer is yes
i did know aaron schwartz
oh boy how much of this is g-rated um
okay for people who don't know the story
of aaron schwartz
um he was uh it's a it's a
it's a sad story um he uh
um he was kind of very much of a
a kind of free software free everything
enthusiast
um who wound up oh downloading a lot of
uh
journal content from jstor and things
through a bunch of computers at mit
and then then somehow he got attacked in
some whole criminal story
and um at the end of it was he he killed
himself
so very a very sad ending but yes i did
know aaron schwartz
i i must say that um uh
we first met aaron schwartz we first
came across erin schwartz because um
uh he had a student version of
mathematica
and the result of that was that his dad
who was a
what i guess usually gets called a
patent troll um
found out had somehow had some patent
that related
to um
[Music]
mathematical typesetting and as a result
of aaron having a student version of
mathematica
the dad who we had some other completely
different connections with
found out about this and we ended up in
this bizarre patent litigation story
um with uh uh with with with the dad
um and uh which um
you know which was kind of silly because
it was a bunch of technology that we'd
we'd invented and um so needless to say
that didn't that didn't um
uh you know we we suitably prevailed in
some way i don't remember the
the whole whole detail of what happened
there but that was that was our
first and rather bizarre introduction to
aaron schwartz was
the kid whose student version of
mathematica caused
a piece of sort of patent trollery then
a few years went by
and then the y combinator paul graham
was starting y combinator which is a uh
startup
uh accelerator that's become very famous
and
and very rich in subsequent years but in
those days this must have been 2004-ish
um it was uh uh paul graham
who'd been kind of a um uh
got a phd in computer science at harvard
i think and then he'd started a company
which was doing an early online store
written in lisp actually
um and uh he ended up selling that
company i think to yahoo
and yahoo rewrote it in in c plus plus
or something like this so
so all the wonders of of that were gone
but anyway paul graham decided to start
this
startup incubator um called y combinator
uh along with um a number of other
people including his now wife jessica
livingston
um and uh they they had bought this
this uh abandoned chocolate factory in
the middle of cambridge massachusetts
to operate the startup incubator very
charming building actually
and so i went there a number of times
when my combinator was just getting
started
and um the um one of the people who was
in the first
cohort of uh uh
of um of y combinator
uh companies that included a bunch of
companies people have heard of like
reddit and so on
but one of those people in that cohort
was erin schwartz
with a company called infogami which was
a some kind of website building company
um and so yes i interact there and in
fact
infogami was one of about three
companies that looked like one of the
more promising ones
that um that we might have had some
business interaction with
um aaron among his other features was he
only ate
white food which was a bit odd um
and uh interesting interesting i don't
know
life choice i don't know whether where
the food is always the same color
you know independent of its state of
cooking and things but in any case that
was one of his
his features um and uh
the um uh we actually
uh had a bunch of interaction with aaron
over
over this whole infogami company which
eventually got folded into reddit
um and uh aaron was involved with that
for a while
and then i'm trying to remember we had i
had some subsequent interactions with
him
um but uh um
that was a very unfortunate story um i
mean i can comment on the
on the the the some of the other players
and the whole dynamics of what happened
were
uh were very odd um between you know
multiple people who
who i think didn't really intend to do
what they intended to do
and and then aaron responding poorly to
the whole thing
and um uh you know i think there was a
certain
degree of kind of um uh sort of
overt activism of yes i'm going to
download all this all this copyrighted
stuff
and i'm going to do it from this
computer in some closet at mit
and it was just a whole very strange
situation but a very
very sad ending to that that story
um there's probably more i'm i'm i'm
thinking there's a there's a
another whole segment to my interactions
with aaron and i'm not forgetting them
so sorry
um
let's see
uh okay there's a question from michael
here is it possible that moving from the
20 original equations used by maxwell
the four we used today we treated
something as negligible by mistake
because quantum theory is not
around there's a piece of that i don't
know because in in maxwell
in his development of the maxwell
equations for electromagnetism
maxwell was not only a good physicist
but also a pretty good expositor and i
certainly have a copy of his original
textbook on electromagnetism
which has the maxwell equations right in
it um
he was his notation is a bit coordinated
for modern tastes a bit explicit in
terms of the use of particular
coordinates
but maxwell invented you know he had
give
div grad and curl he was originally
going to call
curl twirl which would have been very
charming
but it was subsequently i don't really
remember how how it came to be named
curl instead of twirl
um maxwell had um uh we had all kinds of
um
uh interesting things um this is james
clark maxwell
who was um originally from scotland but
spent
much of his career in in in cambridge
um and then sort of went went back to
scotland he died fairly young
um uh he uh um uh
he was some interesting story about
maxwell
is when he was in cambridge you know in
cambridge there are these you know
everybody's doing these all these
sort of very competitive math things and
there's the whole notion
of the senior wrangler who does the best
in the math
exams in cambridge et cetera et cetera
et cetera well
the question is does james james clerk
maxwell very
successful mathematical physicist was he
the senior wrangler
wrangler answered no he was not a guy
called ralph was the senior wrangler
the year that um uh maxwell was
uh sort of supposed to be um what was
doing these exams what happened to ralph
well
if you do mechanics you might have heard
of ralphians um they're
kind of a related to lagrangians and
things like that um
so he did do do some things but i don't
know much about ralph
but maxwell uh well interesting
interesting trap in many ways i mean
i think a lot of sort of charming things
to say about maxwell
i mean he um he had uh
um for example he he entered a
competition
an essay competition in cambridge to
write about uh
the topic i think was the adam's assay
competition i think it still exists
um i think its topic was about the moons
of the the the
rings of saturn to understand the
physics of the rings of saturn
and so for that purpose maxwell figured
out what
became the maxwell boltzmann
distribution the distribution of
velocities for gases
and he did that as part of figuring out
i'm not sure that anybody knows what he
did with the rings of saturn but they
know
the maxwell-waltzman distribution
interestingly if you read his early
papers about that
one of the things he's absolutely
obsessed with is is what happens when
molecules are weird shapes
like if a molecule is the shape of a
wedge or something
what happens when it collides with
another molecule and how does that whole
sort of equilibrium uh work uh it's
interesting because you know he was
obsessed with a lot of details that we
now know don't matter
but in his day he didn't know that they
didn't matter and so he
he considered them that's a very common
thing you see in looking at
historical works of science is there
were things that
people said that might matter let's
chase that particular issue
even though today we kind of know it
doesn't matter and so we don't learn
about that particular thing
i think um maxwell had a whole bunch of
other
interesting ideas i mean i i am uh
for some reason i'm charmed by the fact
that maxwell did a bunch of work on
color vision
and he always used the the um uh
the particular fiducial blue was the
color of his wife's eyes
um and uh that was um sort of a charming
thing
he didn't have children actually i knew
a um
uh a descendant of his when i was in not
direct descendant because he didn't have
children but
a a one step away descendant um
when i was a kid actually that person
has become a
distinguished medical researcher in um
uh in subsequent years but um
in any case the the um uh so maxwell
had uh well a bunch of other things that
were sort of interesting that he did i
mean one thing he was involved with this
idea that had come from kelvin
william thompson the idea that atoms
which were
you know in the time when these people
were working late 1800s were kind of
people were yes matter is really made of
discrete atoms
but what are these atoms well one kind
of charming theory
was that atoms might be nots in the
ether
so at the time uh when maxwell was
working on electromagnetism
he had figured out these equations for
electromagnetism
and among other things um uh those
equations
well predicted the existence of
electromagnetic waves just as in
in um another like 40 years later
um you know einstein would predict the
existence of gravitational waves from
the
equations of general relativity but
maxwell could predict the existence of
electromagnetic waves
and there was a chap called hertz
heinrich hertz i think
who um did this experiment where he had
this kind of spark
gap that would generate electromagnetic
waves and yes
he could receive the signal of those
electromagnetic waves at a distance and
i think people asked hertz
is this going to be useful for anything
he said ah not really it's just proving
that maxwell's
equations for electromagnetism and the
implication that they generate waves
is you know works you know it's a piece
of basic science
um not noticing the fact that
that would turn into radio and would be
a giant story of technology so to speak
it's sort of a charming case of
well i was just doing this experiment to
verify these equations
actually it turned into a giant piece of
technology but in the time of maxwell
people believed that uh if there was a
wave electromagnetic wave it had to be a
wave in something just like sound waves
or waves in
air and so there was this notion of the
luminiferous ether the light carrying
ether
that was the the the thing that would
pervade all of space
in which uh kind of uh electromagnetic
waves would propagate
and so maxwell uh
assumed that there was such a
luminiferous ether and then
was uh the question was could that could
that ether have structure
not just be a a uniform thing in which
the only thing that was going on was it
was electromagnetic waves well one
possibility is that maybe there would be
knots in the ether
some kind of knotted configuration in
the ether and maybe that would
correspond to atoms and it was known at
the time
that there were a limited number of
elements you know maybe 92 or something
of them or whatever it is
um and it's like well could there be
could it be the
case that just for purely mathematical
reasons there are only a limited number
of possible knots in the ether
and that's why there are limited number
of possible kinds of atoms and actually
a
a high school friend of maxwell's i
think maybe college friend
uh named tate um uh got
um maxwell encouraged him to kind of he
was a mathematician tate was a
mathematician
and um uh got tate to classify
knots to try and figure out you know
what are the different possible forms of
knot you know there's a trefoil not
which has you know it's a that's a four
one knot and some
classification of knots and then there
are five one and five two and so on
there's this whole classification of
knots and at the time it wasn't known
whether there are
infinite or finite number of of of truly
distinct
knots and uh so that was the thought
that maybe the knots would correspond to
the different kinds of atoms
it's really a charming idea and it's an
idea that that has a strange resonance
with things that are happening in our
physics project today
i mean it's also an interesting thing
that this idea that there is sort of an
ether
that pervades the universe um in which
uh that is not just space not just the
structure of space but also some
something that exists in space so to
speak
is an idea that has recurred in in
physics many times
and it happened with a luminiferous
ether what happened to the luminaire
first ether well
uh one of the predictions of the
luminiferous ether was that there would
be an ether drift
and that you would be able to see the
effect
of basically uh of moving relative to
this ether
that would affect the propagation of of
electromagnetic waves
um and the michael simoli experiment
that was done around 1900
um uh used the orbit of the earth
as a way to know uh kind of what
direction
um you were going and and they found
that there was no
ether drift there was no uh nothing no
effect
um in the propagation of electromagnetic
waves uh as a result of sort of where
they were
of the motion of the earth so that was
that was one of the things that led to
this kind of
this kind of slightly peculiar situation
that
when it came to mechanical kinds of
things it seemed like
yes you could tell how you were moving
but when it came to
um when it came to electromagnetism one
of the features of maxwell's equations
was that
those equations predicted that light
waves
would always move at the speed of light
regardless of how fast the
the emitter was moving and it was sort
of a question how could this possibly
work
and that was what einstein in 1905
figured out in the special theory of
relativity
was how to sort of distort space and
time to preserve
the the kind of propagation which
magnetic waves at the speed of light
that maxwell's equations had predicted
and often what people said was oh
einstein solved the problem
of how electromagnetic waves could work
even though there was no etherdrift and
so on
even though there was no ether and
people said so there's no ether
and so one of the things that was often
quoted was sort of a statement from
einstein that
sort of you can't tell what your state
of motion is
because there's no you know any state of
motion is equivalent
in the universe if you're going if
you're at rest if you're going at half
the speed of light
there's no fundamental difference you
can never tell the difference between
those two things
well of course that isn't actually true
because the universe
does have a center of gravity that was
discovered in 1962-ish when the cosmic
microwave background was discovered
that's the relic radiation from the big
bang and that defines a preferred rest
frame for the universe
and we know we're moving at about a
thousandth of the speed of light
relative to that preferred rest frame
so it isn't really true even though a
lot of you know the theory of relativity
came from this
belief that there is no ether really
actually in a sense there is sort of an
ether
there is a center of mass for the
universe and when it comes to things
like the higgs mechanism
and so on again it's a story of a thing
like an ether
that sort of pervades the universe in
the case the higgs mechanism giving mass
to particles and so on
in our theories of physics we don't
really have
an ether but we have something even much
more bizarre which is
the theory creates space itself and so
there's no notion of there being an
ether of something in space
because space has sort of created itself
within the model
but um in any case the so that was sort
of a long explanation of
of um of some of what maxwell knew now
of course
maxwell himself uh
was never really confronted i think with
anything which would have led him
to think about quantum mechanics the
thing that was really sort of the in
your face
quantum mechanical story was spectral
lines the fact that
uh like a gas for example would either
emit light
or absorb light in at particular fixed
frequencies at particular
um in particular levels and that was
kind of a like what's going on here type
question
um then you know the thing that actually
led quantum mechanics to be
early part of the discovery of quantum
mechanics was
max planck's uh discovery in 1900 and so
what that was
associated with was some black body
radiation so
you heat something up it's painted black
it's all black it's whatever
it's it's some you just heat stuff up
and it glows glows red hot glows white
hot goes
goes blue hot eventually
that there is a distribution of the
frequencies of photons
associated with a certain temperature
and the question was what is that
distribution and experiments were done
on this
and the most obvious possibility is that
the distribution will be the maxwell
boltzmann distribution
uh e to the minus e over k kt
um that would be a pure exponential
distribution
of um of energies that would be what you
would expect
from various kinds of arguments about um
sort of uh the way that that photons
might work
or the way that the way that um the the
way that um
uh sort of uh electromagnetic energy
might be produced
but that what but that wasn't observed
and planck
observed that actually there's a much
better fit to the distribution
if it isn't e to the minus x so to speak
but rather one over um
e to the x minus one and um
uh so it's like why should it be this
way well the answer is
if there were discrete quanta of
radiation then that would explain why it
works that way
and that was it so it was initially sort
of an empirical observation
then einstein kind of got into the act
and the photoelectric effect
um was it was another place where you
could really see some evidence of the
existence of photons but that was kind
of that story
but maxwell didn't have access to any of
that information and i don't think would
have been in a position to kind of
invent quantum mechanics so to speak
uh mikhail have i met elon musk or steve
jobs yes i
i knew steve i know elon um
could i suppose i could tell you stories
about steve jobs i don't think i'm
prepared to tell stories about
about elon musk this at this point
um let's see
ah okay there's a question from
parmenides
about um who did i meet when i worked at
the institute for advanced study
okay so i worked at the institute for
advanced study from
what was it 1982
[Music]
through 1986 is that right something
like that
so it was sort of interesting because
the institute so the institute for
advanced study was created in the
in the 1930s it was a
the primary source of funding i think
was the macy's department store
family and the chap who um
i think was a chap called abraham
flexner who was the
the um the person who was um uh who
really sort of put the thing together
and kind of its concept was to bring
sort of great thinkers in particularly i
i think math and physics
uh to be in a place where they could
just think and do basic research
uh for the course of their lives so to
speak um and this really got
greatly accelerated when when a lot of
people were leaving germany
in the 1930s and it became sort of a
home for many of those people
including people like einstein and godel
and von neumann and so on um
when uh uh when i was at the institute
well the institute had gone through
through sort of several
uh iterations of different kinds of
people but but
um um one of its prominent directors was
robert oppenheimer
who had led the science part of the
manhattan project
and then after the second world war um
as a result of oh the whole story of
oppenheimer and communism
and etc etc etc wound up uh
sort of um losing his security clearance
in a whole
burst of shame and so on and um
uh was kind of uh installed actually
partly through the i think the
the um the efforts of the guy um uh
strauss i forget his first name the the
general who was responsible for the
actual um
uh the general who had previously built
the pentagon
as a building and who was then assigned
to go run the manhattan project as
a sort of uh uh operational uh leader
but i think that person was was
involved with with gertron oppenheimer
the job of being
director of the institute for advanced
study so oppenheimer
was i think a very very from all
everything i know
from was a very effective and impressive
kind of leader of of of science
innovation and so on
um and he was also a person who who uh
put a lot of effort into kind of picking
the right people for the team so to
speak
and one of the things that happened was
that when he was the director of the
institute
um he really did a good job of picking
the right people for the team so to
speak
but uh and he picked some of the the
most prominent
you know physicists particularly of the
time
uh even when they were quite young uh to
join the institute
but then he he died in 1968 i think and
unfortunately what happened and i
suppose it's the way of an organization
like this
is that uh the the people who
he picked he did a lot of sort of
high-risk hiring he hired a lot of
people who were very promising but he
hired them when they were quite young
when it sort of wasn't clear what the
what the full vector trajectory was
going to be
um and uh you know people like lee and
yang td lee and sian yang
uh were a person called tullio reggie
um just a whole long list of of um
uh people who were um who did very
interesting
uh physics but anyway so so oppenheimer
had done kind of high risk hiring
by the time i was at the institute most
of the
the biggest payoff people from the
high-risk hiring
had through the random processes of
different opportunities
left leaving the the
not quite so successful uh results of
high-risk hiring
particularly in the physics area but um
in any case in the the physics area was
much more oppenheimer
higher than other areas the mathematics
area
i think people had typically been hired
much later in their careers
and the vectors were much much much
clearer so to speak
um i think that the um uh
the thing that um um
[Music]
yeah so i mean it is a strange thing to
say to people
okay you know at age whatever
for the rest of your life just think
about basic science stuff
don't have to worry about anything else
sounds really cool
in practice that's a difficult thing for
people to do
um and uh uh so who did i know there
let's see they used to have tea every
day i used to go to it
and there were people like andre vay uh
well-known
mathematician who would show up and um
uh um there were people
uh some some still alive like uh bob
langlins and so on
um uh the uh people um
a whole whole collection of um the math
people i i guess the math people i knew
best um
uh uh happily still alive jack milner
um was one uh john milner uh
enrico bombieri number theorist another
one but
jack milner i think the thing i always
found most charming about
jack is that um actually
he got very interested in cellular
automata that i was working on
and we kind of did a whole bunch of work
sort of together um
and i think one of the things that was
most notable was that jack
tried really hard to like figure stuff
out about cellular automata it was very
frustrated how difficult it was to do
that
and i think that's kind of what we now
understand is that sort of the story
of computational irreducibility is it's
really hard to use
traditional mathematical methods you you
kind of you're
face to face with undecidability so to
speak uh very quickly
um when you when you start working on
things like this but anyway the thing
that that i would
say most charmed me about jack uh
that um was done a lot of very
interesting mathematics and i would ask
him do you know about such and such a
thing
it says nah i don't know about that so
then i would go and look in the library
and i'd go find a bunch of stuff
and i discovered that actually the key
paper about such and such as thing
was written by none other than jack
milner you know some 20 30 years earlier
and so i'd show this to jack and he
would say
oh yeah i remember that now so i i've
sometimes characterized him as the
person who's forgotten more mathematics
than uh than most people will ever know
um
but you know there were other people who
were around the institute there was a
person called julian bigelow
who had been the engineer who'd worked
on uh
john von neumann's computer at the
institute
i remember i was was was there when
there was a
group of people uh so so when von
neumann died
in 1956 um he had built this computer
at the institute for advanced study and
was in the the computer building it was
still called the computer building
um when uh when i was there
um when he died the um
at least the the um the the anecdote was
that tom watson from ibm um had said
oh you know uh you know
i'm happy to send a truck and get rid of
that that uh that computer that you
don't want anymore
um but uh anyway when i was there there
was a person called herman goldstein who
had been a part of the von neumann
computer project
who had gone to work at ibm at that time
who came back to give a talk about
about some the history of the computer
project and so on
and um i kind of raised the question
with there's a group of mathematicians
from the institute including people like
andre bay
and so on uh who had been there at the
time when von neumann was there
i kind of asked the question did you
guys know what was going to happen with
computers you know
when von neumann died the kind of
general the general vibe was
the mathematicians that said we don't
want this nasty messy computer
here just get rid of it you know we
don't want it
so i kind of asked this question uh you
know did you guys know what was going to
happen with computers
and and what ensued was this
unfortunately it's probably not
um not recorded but it was an
interesting exchange it was a very
aggressive exchange
between um uh the various sort of
old-time mathematicians
and and um and herman goldstein i think
it was another person from ibm there
also
i i think the um uh you know claiming
counter-claiming whatever about about to
what extent mathematicians could sort of
foresee
the importance of computers um but
anyway
when when i was at the institute there
was still julian bigelow was still there
um and uh was sort of a
not not clear what um uh you know it's
not clear what what he had had a chance
to do
after the von neumann computer project
had had ended which had been
a full you know uh whatever 25 years
earlier
um other people well gosh
all the usual cast of characters my gosh
i mean the
people like freeman dyson was certainly
there i saw him at lunch practically
every day
he i'm afraid i didn't always get on
with him terribly well he he had a habit
of
of coming and saying um uh you know i
have this great idea
which usually had gotten some somebody
else and i would point out
uh wait a minute freeman how can that
possibly be right blah blah blah blah
blah
and he and he would be very um uh
very sort of fall into silence and i
kind of be growling at me
but uh and i i learned actually
subsequently i mean freeman died
a year or two ago and actually i
happened to exchange mail with him
uh i happened to see him i hadn't seen
him in years
um see him a few years ago and exchanged
mail with him and i have to say his
his um uh he always
um well freeman was a was a contrarian
whenever everybody would say one thing
freeman would always try and say the
opposite and i remember at various kinds
of um
uh uh kind of administrative meetings at
the institute freeman
um being there and freeman would always
just take the the completely contrary
point of view
to whatever was being said um but
uh i was um was kind of charmed when my
new kind of science book came out um
freeman always given to the the um uh
you know
saying the the dramatic thing some
journalist asked him
about this book and and so he said about
me
um he said uh uh
you know oh he's a very precocious chap
um
he's even precocious in you know in
coming up with the sort of grand theory
of everything
um you know usually people have to be
very old before they get sort of um
uh kind of uh fuddy-duddy enough
to think that they have ground theories
of everything you know uh he's he's
doing this
this um uh you know in a
in a precocious way at age 40 or
whatever whatever it was
so um anyway i didn't know whether you
know this was
sort of quoted by a journalist i happen
to know who who
said yeah yeah freeman really did say
that but i didn't know what he actually
did so i
i i thought i would would ask him and
there's just a
couple of years ago and um and so i did
and so freeman responded yes yes he
really did say that he really thought
all this work was complete nonsense so i
said well freeman
you know i've known you for how many
years and it's like
the first time you you know that this is
the first time you're kind of telling me
to my face that you think
all my work is nonsense um you know
that's a bit odd
uh you know you had a chance to do that
you know when i worked at the institute
and you never did that and um it's a
little odd that
you know uh 35 more years go by before
you kind of have the um
uh have the have the opportunity to say
that to me
quite in person an email whatever um
strange situation
but um uh there were people um
there was sort of still the the kind of
a little bit of the the um
uh talk about godel at the institute for
advanced study so godel
uh godel died in the early 1970s i guess
um and uh um many people
had known him who i knew and um know i
think godel
uh the i remember being interested to
see some documents from godel in the
archives of the institute and it's like
no no no
nobody can see those those are those uh
you know those are sealed those are
you know i don't actually know why and
maybe they've been unsealed now but
but at the time at least there was i
think some embarrassment because
i think the institute did not treat
godel particularly well
i think that he was he was never really
um uh
never really treated as a sort of full
full-fledged
you know uh fully plumed member of the
whole
the whole establishment um but
uh uh that was um
let's see other people um
uh well yeah i i've certainly met many
many interesting characters that um at
the institute i could um
uh see there's a problem that there's
stories of the ancient
past which i have found by by historical
research
i think are all sort of uh um
fair game i think so many things that i
know from
actual details of individual people and
my interactions with them
and things which even when the people
are dead it's not clear
you know i i kind of haven't worked out
what my principles are about
about what to say and not to say i mean
there certainly are interesting stories
um i'll i'll relate one about girdle and
a person called john mccall john because
was a
astrophysicist at the institute uh when
i was there
um i think um
well uh he he'd been um
when he was first there he'd been he'd
been hired i think in the in the robert
oppenheimer
crowd um the uh uh
the girdle was there and apparently he'd
been john mccall told me this story at
least
that um uh you know he'd been telling
godel very excitedly about all the stuff
he was doing with
you know uh working out distributions of
stars and galaxies and all this kind of
thing
and apparently girdle said um at the end
of that he said um
uh young man that's all very nice but i
do not believe in natural science
so and in a sense girdle
uh you know the notion of induction of
deducing things from experiment
was something uh you know it was it was
an interesting comment i think that um
you know i do not believe in natural
science now god will also uh you know he
would he would make a lot of these
statements apparently
like um uh you know when people would
tell him about some results
he would say i'll be interested to see
that in print
what does that mean well in modern times
it would be like show me a peer-reviewed
journal that has
accepted this thing type thing so i
suppose wasn't wasn't that different
from that
um i mean goodwill became quite a
recluse in his later years
um i think uh um had all kinds of
medical problems really didn't trust
doctors perhaps for good reasons in some
cases
that caused him all kinds of trouble but
um uh there were just
a lot of a lot of strange stories about
godel and people um
um uh well kind of the proof of the
independence of the continuum hypothesis
by cohen i think there's a
there's a a bunch of strange stories
about that and about um
uh the um uh kind of taking the document
of that and
sort of putting it under girdle's door
and um
uh you know i i don't remember all the
details of that story but it was it was
very much of a recluse type story
um right
let's see um oh yeah actually the
the there's a question about uh palmetto
is asking about homotopic type theory
you know i haven't
i've been back at the institute only a
couple of times since since the 1980s so
one time i happened to be at a hackathon
in princeton
and i went to visit uh vervodsky
um vladimir watsky i forget the name who
was the um
uh originator of of the whole sort of
homotopic type theory
and use of proof assistant in that area
thing it was a sunday morning and
and um um we had a long
long long conversation uh volvodski
unfortunately ended up
uh committing suicide a little bit a
little bit after that
um but um he um uh
um it was a conversation about kind of
the the role of proof assistance versus
the role of
of uh mathematical computation and kind
of the future of mathematics and so on i
would say it was some
um
somehow
the kind of was interesting to
see uh
well a thing that um
um see a good mathematician kind of try
and absorb
what was possible to do in the world of
tooling so to speak for mathematics
i do have to tell one story which is a
kind of a second-hand story so it's
i really like my stories when that when
they are sort of fully validated by my
own experience so this one
is sort of second hand okay and it
relates to bob langland's the creator of
the langlens program
a very distinguished mathematician at
the institute
a um a former student of mine worked at
the institute
after i was there and after mathematica
existed
and uh bob langens was was wanted to use
mathematica and so on and my
former student had the had the task of
teaching him
how to use it and so on and as i said
there's a second
secondhand story so i can't verify this
first hand but
but apparently the the most charming
thing that happened was that bob
langland's
kind of went to the student of mine and
said you know
so you know he's trying to understand at
a more foundational level
how computers work and so you know his
only exposure to
actual use of computers was using
wolfram language and using mathematica
and using
uh transformation rules for symbolic
expressions and so on
and so he developed this kind of theory
of how computers must work
that had to do with the idea that they
are based on transformation rules for
symbolic expressions and my
my former student was was kind of like
no i'm sorry actually that's not how
they really work it's
it's in a sense it's much less
interesting how they actually work
of course it's charming now uh with the
things i was looking at recently with
the history of combinators and so on
invented in 1920 which were sort of the
origin of this idea of transformational
rules and symbolic expressions
you know but for the details of history
uh bob langlins might have been right
and computers might have been based on
transformation rules for symbolic
expressions
rather than out on boolean algebra and
switching circuits and logic and so on
um but i just thought it was a charming
kind of inference i mean that's a
that's a uh you know inductive uh you
know an inductive
mode of doing science how does the
computer really work inside
um and uh you know it's interesting to
see what you can conclude from that
oh boy let's see um
uh questions here
um people asking about different kinds
of people okay so have i met people
related to the human genome project yeah
sure i have
uh certainly i mean eric lander who just
just got tapped to be a
science advisor to the president in the
us
and who has been running the broad
institute for a while i don't know him
terribly well
um uh craig venter uh yes i've certainly
met him
i think um uh
one of the things i you know when the
human genome project was first coming
online and craig vanta was kind of
saying you know he's going to do it
kind of the commercial route as opposed
to this very very very slow government
route i was like
that that's good that's probably going
to work and it did a lot of the
innovation there had to do with
you know once you smashed the genome up
into these you know length 30 sequences
and things
how do you do all the sort of computer
puzzle solving to fit all those together
it was really
a story of large-scale computation among
other things
but um i i did wonder to myself right
from the very beginning
i was like whose genome is it going to
be
that you know gets sequenced and um
you know in the end it sort of came out
a decent part of the genome was craig
venter's genome and i was like of course
why not you don't have to get permission
if it's your own genome
the uh uh but anyway i thought that was
amusing i i
i am you know he published his genome i
remember asking him once um
whether he had children and because of
course that's an issue i mean like i got
my genome sequence back in 2010
and um you know one of the reasons i
mean i might decide just for my own
kind of uh you know like put this genome
out
on on the web but you know i have four
kids and um
it's you know in a sense by putting my
genome out on the web i'm also putting
half of all their genomes out on the web
too
and that's it's not clear that it's not
just for yourself to put your whole
genome out on the web so i was
i was craig venter does have kids and it
seemed like he hadn't actually thought
about that question
um of um uh
but in any case yeah i am
i mean there are other people um um
uh yes i mean the the i remember
actually back
i was a consultant at los alamos in the
early 1980s and there was some
a person called george bell who ran the
theory division there
at the time and um he was a person
very early person in um uh
uh let's see there's another chap there
too um
walter maybe trying to remember the name
i don't remember the name
um but um anyway they were they were
just starting to do kind of physicists
arrive in life sciences type work
and in particular interested in in um
uh kind of genome sequences and and they
were
involved in starting i think they maybe
started genbank the original
uh thing that turned into the ncbi you
know database of genomes that exists
today
but that was a thing that was i mean los
alamos had primarily been
a nuclear weapons lab um sort of became
more of a physics lab and this was sort
of an effort to
to get into something you know
physicists meat biology type thing
and what was interesting was one of the
things that was interesting was was the
the whole process by which sort of
genetic data
got to be published and made available
to people and because it's something
people have asked you know many other
fields how will data be made available i
mean
you know there are lots of fields some
where people like produce a lot of data
and it's like well the government says
you should publish this data
but it never really happens and people
always sort of hang on to it and
it's kind of like well it was my
experiment and i want to keep doing
stuff with that data et cetera et cetera
et cetera
um i think that um the
um in the case of genbank and so on
what happened was the i believe the
journal of nucleic acid research
said we'll only publish your papers if
you deposit your sequences in genbank
and that was kind of the mechanism by
which sort of forced
the development of these kind of
centralized databases of genetic
information
it's an interesting interesting story
for for other attempts to kind of
force the existence of if if possible
computable data
associated with um uh um with these with
these kinds of things
i remember talking of those kinds of
things i mean uh kind of
sort of in the news should be in the
news these days uh sydney brenner
um who was uh uh the discoverer of
messenger rna which is
you know the thing used for this couple
of the the the vaccines that are that
are now out
um the uh uh i did know sydney brenner
who died um
maybe two three years ago now um uh he
was always a very um
uh it was a biologist um
who uh uh was very computationally
oriented
and very interested in in whether one
could make sort of a computational
view of biology and actually was always
telling me
you know what you really got to work on
is biology you know take all this
computational stuff you've done
and apply it to biology and he had
various theories about how to do it i
i think i have all kinds of notes he
wrote out um
uh when we were talking about about this
kind of thing and he had sort of
uh particular ideas about how this would
work and so on
and um uh just a big enthusiast for um
uh sort of making i mean really thought
of biology i think in a
in in some sort of fundamentally
computational way i think he was sort of
frustrated that he couldn't get more
people to pay attention to this he was
in addition to doing mrna and many other
things he was also the person who
kind of promoted the idea and ran the
the effort
to take the c elegans nematode worm and
be able to map out the complete
structure of where
it's all its cells go as kind of a model
organism
but um i would say um
uh well a history historical micro
anecdote
um maybe i've told before here i'm not
sure
um was uh talking to sydney brenner one
day
about alan turing um and i don't
think sydney burns had never met alan
turing but sydney brenner
uh worked at king's college cambridge
where well i'm turing had been
and was responsible for sort of the uh
development of a touring archive at
king's college cambridge
um and um uh i had mentioned that i
noticed that in the serratura in alan
turing's mother's book
about alan turing it mentions at the end
of the book something
about how alan turing's later work on on
phylotaxis and biological development
was getting letters from all over the
world about things about things related
to that including from places far away
as south africa
well south africa was where sydney
banner came from turns out he wrote that
letter to alan turing
asking about some uh his work on
biological development
um but that's just one of those micro
pieces of
of history um
a question about um
uh let's see
did i interact with claude shannon sadly
no i did not
um claude shannon i knew a bunch of
people at mit who knew called shannon
um i should have made more of an effort
to interact with him in the 1980s i
didn't
um when i kind of really got around to
it in the 1990s
um his wife kind of explained that he
was uh
you know his memory had declined and
kind of
was protecting him from from outside
interaction so so i never had a chance
to meet him
um i think it was a an interesting movie
about him the biographical film that
came out about him recently
that i thought was was quite good um
but uh uh yeah i don't know i mean the
story of claude shannon and his work
on um sort of applying boolean algebra
to switching
circuits which was his um i think his
master's
thesis is that right at mit and then he
went to bell labs
and worked on um well his most famous
contribution is information theory
um exactly what the interaction between
claude shannon and alan turing about
information theory was is not clear
i mean you know originally one of the
great interests of information theory
was if you have an encrypted message
and you want to know uh sort of how much
data do you need to be able to have a
chance to find the password to decrypt
this message
you kind of need to know how how much
redundancy is there
in the original message that would kind
of allow you to get cryptanalysis
started
and i think that was the original
motivation for developing information
theory was this question
about kind of the script analysis
question which came up
in in world war ii and um the uh
sort of interesting that um um
in um uh uh alan turing one of his big
contributions at bletchley park
in the code breaking effort was
essentially a statistical idea
that is is about um uh
i guess about the the um a prior
and apostolia or a probabilities of
various um
kinds of things to do with key
distribution and i'm now forgetting the
details of it
i do remember that that um i think alan
turing's boss at bletchley park was a
person called
uh jack good ij good uh who i met once
uh in his later years uh met him at a
conference about theoretical biology
he'd become very interested in
theoretical biology he actually i think
was the person who coined the term
the singularity and he was sort of
interested in the
in the ultimate future of biological
evolution and things like that
interesting old at the time when i met
him chap but anyway the
jack goode had was a statistician
originally and
um was sort of a person involved with
touring statistical work
and exactly how that overlapped with
what sort of became the shannon
information theory uh work i'm not sure
i know that um uh alan turing and claude
shannon met
um uh alan turing was working on a
speech incitement system
called delilah um which was some kind of
i think the the um
uh i think it was uh it was sort of a
british version and there was an
american version
and i forget which was which but one of
the versions maybe the american version
it was a wonderful system the only
problem was that
the equipment for it was the size of a
room so you could make like
maybe you know winston churchill and
franklin roosevelt could have
have you know have versions of this but
it wasn't exactly field deployable
um but anyway the the um alan turing um
came to the us in world war ii and went
to the
bell labs building which was then in the
middle of new york city
um and uh and met with claude shannon
there i know that that um
there's sort of some funny stories about
how the the whole paperwork of alan
turing's visit was
was all rather scrambled and so he was
like hanging out not able to go into the
building for
for some period of time and so on but um
it's uh i don't think it's really known
what happened in that meeting or maybe
it was a completely uninteresting
meeting i
i don't know but i don't really i don't
really understand quite the
the um uh the the distribution of those
ideas
um our comment from pomenti pomenites
the french
composer eric satty would only eat white
food too
interesting um
let's see
pimentes is asking for anecdotes about
edwin and leonard
suskind too alive i think
for too many anecdotes um
the
um
it's a question
let's see
oh boy there's a question here from
meeps about
fischer information and roy friedan and
physics from fischer information
i have a copy of that book i haven't
read it
actually fisher information is probably
related
to a um oh gosh what is it called
uh a metric which may occur
in our multi-way systems um
oh boy it's a double-barreled name and
it slips my mind
um but uh sort of related to that i mean
there's a whole gaggle of ideas
that i think are all connected the
maximum entropy principle of jane's
and a bunch of other kind of ideas that
i think originated in the 1950s 1960s
um and i may be being unfair to the the
whole question about fisher information
um but it's my impression that that one
of the issues is when you make models of
things
there's a question there may be there
will be in general when you have a
certain amount of experimental data
there will be many possible models
consistent with that experimental data
how do you pick the best one in a sense
you typically want a model where you put
a little bit in you get a lot out
but it's a good fit to the data how do
you know how do you trade off
sort of the good fit to the data versus
the model versus whatever
and at any time in history people are
always claiming
that oh we have the model this model it
will fit any data
neural nets people often say that about
it's a sort of modelless model
it will fit any data well it's never
true i mean neural nets are particular
sets of nested functions
and they'll fit some data they won't fit
others and you can you can bash them
hard enough that they'll fit almost
anything if you have enough parameters
in the neural nets
but at various times people sort of said
this is this is the way to kind of get
something for nothing
and have a model this model you know an
assumptionless model
and maximum information maximum entropy
was one of these approaches
that kind of there are situations in
which
when you have to choose between
different distributions that could
describe some data
you choose a maximum entropy one and
sometimes there's a good physical reason
for that being the right choice
and sometimes there isn't and so
sometimes the method works and sometimes
it doesn't
and people tend to have this idea oh my
gosh it's a magic method it's going to
work everywhere
um and and that's that's sort of almost
by definition not going to be the case
but so that that often leads to you know
in in certain areas these sort of black
magic
type type um uh notions i mean
another one that i remember from years
ago was when you're trying to find the
global minimum of a function you have a
function it's wiggling around all over
the place
it's like give me an algorithm that
finds the global minimum
well that's really hard because this
function could have just all kinds of
crazy stuff going on it could have a
little
tiny hole somewhere in the middle and
you know if you know the functional form
yes you can you can work on things there
but if you if just given empirical data
it's like uh or if you have a generator
of the function
if you just have a program that
generates the values of the function
it's it's
really really hard it's sort of
undecidable question um you know in
general what will happen with this
function but yet
there end up being these sort of magic
algorithms that find these things
and they're always magic within a
certain class of functions or whatever
and it's sometimes very confusing to see
what those boundaries are
um
let's see
um
oh i'm sorry i'm i'm roberto is
commenting about vervodsky
um the the wikipedia says
that um he did not kill himself so maybe
i'm wrong about that i
i know he died and that was uh and i'm
i'm
i apologize if that was if that was
incorrect
um and uh
um let's see
it's a question from david what's a good
place to get one's genome sequenced
well uh the company that does an awful
lot of these is illumina
um and it's it's um that's uh when i got
my genome sequence in 2010
uh i think i was a one of the first few
tens of humans who did that and we
happened to be doing some work with with
illumina at the time
um it was kind of charming because
because in the end
the thing arrives in this big box and
it's like
why is my genome in a big box and you
open the box and you open the box there
are more and more layers and more and
more layers
and eventually there's a thumb drive in
the middle that has the um
uh that has the actual data on it um
but um uh you know what's happened is
there's been a sequence of different
technologies for doing genome sequencing
and um uh i think some of them have
wound up
uh sort of being acquired by illumina i
think there are some independent ones
um that they're just these different
ideas for how to sequence genomes
um that have come up including some some
i mean there's
this sort of the uh one of the more
exotic ones was an idea due to
um let's see a company called halcyon
molecular this is a weird story
as a silicon valley company um
that um it's kind of a sad story
actually
the um uh the company had this idea uh
started by two brothers who were very
sort of futuristically oriented but they
had the idea
of basically just stretching out a dna
molecule
so that it was uh so it was sort of all
uh
kind of stretched out and then
essentially using an electron microscope
to just basically outright look at the
dna molecule
and see what the sequence of base pairs
was kind of an interesting technology
idea
anyway i went to visit this company in
silicon valley at some point and it was
interesting because
among other things it had a lot of
electron microscopy experts there
and um electron microscopy was not a
field that had progressed that much in
many years
and a lot of the equipment was you know
like sort of
uh you know very old designs and so on
and it was very
uh interesting that this was a company
was really trying to push the state of
the art of electron microscopy
and um uh the uh was kind of doing a lot
of
uh of strange and interesting research
unfortunately two weeks after i visited
the company
the people who were funding the company
decided to
just stop paying and the company kind of
just completely imploded um and
that was a result of kind of this uh
what was it oxford now poor company or
whatever that was
had announced these results on on a
different approach to sequencing i'm not
sure that approach has actually worked
out yet
um but in any case the the um uh
um the thing that um this is um
uh um
[Music]
um the the uh so so
it was a rare case usually usually um
in the words of a friend of mine who is
a well-known venture capitalist and
silicon valley asked him these companies
you know when a company has started
and it doesn't make it you know often
it's very strange to interact with a
company that has
a startup that's been going and it's
been going it's been going it doesn't
really make it
and and i sort of asked him you know
what happens
and his basic claim is that you know
first of all you know all the better
people leave because they can get other
jobs
and in the end you know it's the last
few programmers
you know sitting around playing
minecraft until
you know until the the lights get
switched off so to speak
but so usually in silicon valley in the
world of startup companies and things
you don't see this kind of you know hits
a wall at 200 miles an hour type type
phenomenon
you kind of more see this multiple years
of just well the company is sort of
doing something it sort of isn't and
and you know of course then there are
exceptions that prove the rules so to
speak because occasionally there'll be
companies
that are in that kind of you know wind
down near-death state
and then suddenly they'll have a new
idea or the world will change
and up they jump right back up again and
uh
and they become you know significant
companies so so it's it's not
um uh the fact that that but there's a
rare case in the case of halcon
molecular
of of actually a company where you visit
it uh one week and then two weeks later
it's gone and um uh that's a kind of an
unfortunate thing
um let's see
uh
questions about joseph fourier um
and how he led to the how he developed
the math that led to the fourier
transform
i don't know that much about joseph
fourier um
i know a few sort of trivia facts
i mean his his main day job i think is
that he was an egyptologist
he went with napoleon napoleon was sort
of a big enthusiast of uh
egyptian um uh culture and
history and when napoleon was in egypt
he brought along his team of
egyptologists and i believe fourier was
one of those people
um his uh his theory of heat which was
the the thing that caused him to develop
fourier analysis and so on
i'm not sure when that was developed
relative to his time in egypt
but is my impression that he was
primarily a i think he may have also
been a minor
uh administrator of of perhaps some some
um
uh in the napoleonic period um in france
but i'm afraid i don't know much about
him i'm sorry um
the uh
let's see um
ah there's a question again from
parmenides about
uh about godel and did i read girdle's
uh citizenship hearing
and um yeah this is a there's a famous
story i don't know whether there's
a written version of this that's really
accurate i mean i i can tell you the
anecdote i can't vouch for it for its
validity
so apparently um uh uh when godel
was going to become a u.s citizen um
einstein
who is a friend of his uh sort of
agreed to give him a ride over to to you
know um
see this judge who is doing the
citizenship hearing
and godel said you know i have studied
the us constitution
and um in principle there is a way
for the u.s to become a dictatorship if
this and this and this happens and this
and this person dies and so on and so on
and so on
and einstein apparently said just don't
mention that
in this hearing um because obviously
that was a time
now godel in a sense godel
in thinking about those kinds of things
was thinking about something which
is very modern it was thinking about
kind of the computational contract idea
the idea of thinking about legal code as
a sort of computational thing
and it's something where you can you can
kind of reason about in a logical way
it's kind of kind of the i mean
this is an essential an old story
because you know leibniz when he was
developing his ideas about
about logic and mathematics and so on
you know his original thing was
you know he's training to be a lawyer he
wrote his phd thesis
uh for law of thesis so to speak on the
subject of you know
resolving difficult cases using logic i
mean his notion was
use something which would eventually be
his sort of
universal computation idea as a way to
think about legal cases and resolve
legal arguments and so on so that sort
of had a long history
girdle had another kind of sideline
which was a
a um uh is interested in applying these
what we would now think of as
computational ideas to many things
including uh he had a proof of i think
it was the proof of the existence of god
um which is sort of a and i think
there's a class of these
these arguments that i think date back
to
ansel maybe aquinas i'm not sure that uh
that are a particular logical structure
of um
uh you know i don't know i'm not going
to do justice to these things but you
know
um uh that some of them i think are are
arguments by based on orderings of of
you know
there is always a greater something or
other therefore there must be an end to
this ordering and that end to that
ordering
uh we must consider to be whatever but
but anyway
um godel has a has one of these there's
a quite long and elaborate um
um uh i have a book which has a
collection of these
theological uh logic kinds of
kinds of things and girdles one of them
i i haven't i have to say i haven't read
it
um and i'm not sure it's a i think
actually
um uh in our find equational proof
system
in wolfram language we can now encode
the predicate logic that is needed
to do some of these and i think maybe
one of the examples there
is one of the simpler uh sort of logical
proofs of the existence of god
so um
let's see i'm going to have to go soon
here but but um
i'm um
stories about um
well people asking about stories about
steve jobs
and um uh
what can i tell you about steve jobs i
mean i
i am uh so i first interacted with steve
jobs
when mathematica was under development
and um
we were starting to look around for how
we would
distribute the software that we were
building and my original idea was
that the the best way to distribute
software at the time this is this is
1987 or so 1986.97
was uh just bundle it with hardware
um you know that the hardware is being
sold by companies
they have operating systems on their
computers this is
something that enables things that um
uh you know should be bundled with the
computers and so this was
kind of my strategy number one for
for the distribution of mathematica it's
still a strategy i very much believe in
for distribution of wolverine language
um and it's you know
in the end one day i don't know how many
more decades it will be before this is
this is i hope very few i hope less than
one um before this is
widespread understood but you know
this notion of when you walk up to a
computer what does it have inside it
you know it has an operating system it
has a user interface
well i think it should have
computational intelligence
it should have basically our
computational language and that was kind
of my idea
back in the in in when we were first
building mathematica
well so i um
uh uh ended up um
um i guess the person who was sort of
the intermediary
who i forget how steve first got
involved with this um but mike hawley
was the person who was um who was a
person who
had worked at pixar was then working at
um
um uh
at next which was steve jobs company at
that time
um the uh he um he was sort of the
intermediary
uh he subsequently went and worked for
many years at the media lab at mit
unfortunately died recently rather young
um but
uh um the um
he was kind of the the somehow he was
involved in sort of the the intermediary
but anyway i
i it was it was through that um that
process that i that i got to know steve
jobs
and and steve kind of made this deal it
was the
first deal we made for distributing
mathematica was the deal to bundle it on
the next computer
which didn't exist yet at that time and
actually
when we finally announced mathematica on
june 23 1988
steve was kind enough to come to our
announcement event which created quite a
stir
because he'd been not seen in silicon
valley for quite a while and he was sort
of
uh showed up to to be part of our
announcement event so that was that was
that was nice of him
but um uh he was um uh
you know one of the things that i always
liked about him
was he just was very uh i would say
um kind of an abstract thinker
in terms of just drill until you get to
the main point
you know whatever it is there are lots
of details there are lots of things
just what's the main point you know
drill drill drill until you get to the
main point
and then build back up from that main
point to figure out so what should you
actually do from an engineering point of
view et cetera et cetera et cetera
and um uh i think he was very taken with
a bunch of features of
of uh of mathematica and so on and the
things it could do
um i think that um
in uh it was it was funny when when
steve jobs well
so steve jobs had been at apple he'd
kind of been ousted
in the in the um uh um
uh john scully period um he'd gone to
start this company called next
um which was a company which i'm afraid
it's one of those cases
which one kind of learns from watching
in one's own life and other people's
lives
it was a little bit too easy it was like
steve had done you know he'd done the
apple ii he'd done the mac
it was like i'm going to do another
computer i know what to do
i'm just going to turn the crank i'm
going to go make a wonderful other
computer
well i i kind of felt like it was like i
i know what to do i'm going to just do
it
and i think that wasn't the best formula
for having
the biggest success and it was um
uh but but next was
um uh there's a company with a lot of
very interesting people
um and uh the product that it made
the next computer was was a cool thing
and it was originally
you know steve thought that education
would be a sort of a key market for it
um i'm not sure that that the the
universities and so on
were in the end as as as kind to the
next
as steve thought that they would be um
and uh uh you know for a while it was
kind of the ultimate stylish computer
you know
if you saw a ceo with a next computer on
their desk you'd know they were cool
type thing
and it had a very nice industrial design
for a black box type
design um you know one of the places
that ended up buying next computer so
so so steve's calculation was you know
pay a certain amount of money to bundle
mathematica on every next computer that
went out um
and his calculation was so some people
will buy the computer just to get the
software
and as was not uncommon with steve he
was absolutely right
even though you know really buying the
whole computer
just to get this piece of software for
free didn't make a lot of sense
people ended up doing it one place that
did it was the theory division at cern
where uh tim berners-lee was kind of the
system administrator
and so we had kind of the the footnote
to a footnote to history so to speak
that you know the original web was
developed on that network of computers
at cern that were had originally been
bought for the purpose of running
uh mathematica by a bunch of theoretical
physicists
um but in any case the the um uh when we
were
so one of the things that came up in
um uh in kind of
mathematica on next and so on was what
we going to call this thing
so originally the original name for
mathematica was omega
and it's sort of funny that in many
years we went from omega
to alpha and that point has been noted
by many people
at least internal to us for a long time
the
the creator id is probably still true
the official mac
creator id for a what's now wolf
notebook
was omeg which was originally burnt in
there
when when um uh when mathematica was
called omega
but anyway we went through um uh omega
was the first name then there was
polymath that was a very
briefly brief name then there was uh
technique and then um and then i was
just
just obsessing about naming and so on
and i was talking to steve about it
and he's like uh you know not not in
real time but it sort of came back to me
and said
the name you should use is mathematica
and and i had considered that name
and had thought it was too long i didn't
really want to burn mathematics so much
into the name
but that was its sort of killer app at
the beginning but it was interesting
that he kind of had this whole
theory of you know he was very taken
with the name trinitron which was the
name that
sony used for its um uh for its
uh um uh televisions that was you know
that televisions in those days had had
sort of i guess they had did they have
three electron guns i'm not sure
it was time of of um cathode ray tube
television
so so um but in any case the the thing
was
you know he had this kind of theory of
take a generic term for something
and romanticize it you know latinize it
whatever else
and i thought it was an interesting kind
of uh thought experiment in
in naming of things but uh
yeah i mean you know i think one of the
things that um
uh was always interesting about steve
went even when he was back at apple
after apple
bought next and so on and um
uh uh he was very um was a good emailer
i mean you would send a mail
any time of day or night there's a good
chance you'd get an answer
you know within an hour um and and it
was usually quite direct
and was either sometimes positive
sometimes negative but it was a very
clear
kind of communication of of um uh of um
uh of of the of whatever it was
and i remember when wolf and alpha was
first coming out uh
telling steve about this and he just
like i don't get it i don't see why i
would care
et cetera et cetera et cetera then when
when siri
was developed by some people at sri and
they kind of sort of packaged with an
offer api
and put this kind of voice assistant
idea around it
when steve saw that he said oh now i get
it i understand why i care about this
and um you know one of the things about
steve that i think is something
to learn from is he could change his
mind
sometimes people thought that was a you
know a deficiency i thought it was a
virtue
um because i thought that you know it's
like you don't always get the whole
story at the beginning
and you don't always know what's what's
going on at the beginning and the world
changes
and i think steve was always always kind
of you know
trying to think about sort of what was
the key point and
what did that mean for what the world
was going to do and you know
do you really need to have you know
interchangeable batteries in your phone
or not is that really an important thing
is that the point
and i think that um you know people
sometimes say oh steve is just a
marketing guy
it's not true he was a guy who
understood the point of things
and you know no he was not the person
who solved all the technical problems i
sometimes
sometimes i was surprised at his
comparative
lack of understanding of some of the
sort of deep technical engineering
details of things
but that wasn't his point his point was
sort of what's the point
and his point was to define you know
this is the key point
this is the direction to go in okay
engineers go figure out how to make this
work
it was not you know his wasn't a
i'm gonna write the code and and uh and
show you how to make it work
his was just uh you know this is the
main point which the engineers on the
ground would not see
um but defining the main points and then
yes
from an engineering point of view this
is where we have to go and obviously if
engineers who he trusted
told him it's just outright impossible
he would change his mind but uh you know
i think that the key thing was
understanding what the key thing was so
to speak
in in a lot of these different areas and
i know steve
was always interested you know i i think
i can't remember
exactly but i i you know i certainly
don't remember the actual conversation
but i i certainly have the impression
that he's sort of
you know maybe he told me this
explicitly he was like if i hadn't done
this computer stuff i would have been a
scientist
and you know whether he would have liked
academia i'm not sure
but as a as a person to kind of drill
down and figure out what's the essential
point of things
you know he was good at that that was
that was that was the real skill
and i think that people talk about his
reality distortion field
of kind of defining an objective and
just saying this is how the world is
even if it doesn't look that way
i was amused that um uh in in the work
we're doing in our physics project
and these entanglement cones that are
the analog of light cones and quantum
mechanics
um i did mention the term a reality
distortion
cone or something uh in kind of homage
to steve's reality distortion field
but but you know this is the nature of
of doing projects
that are kind of uh sort of out in front
that they seem impossible and the only
way that
you know you you just have to say
they're you know there are things that
are
you know that make it seem like it's
impossible and like just
ignore those just don't concentrate on
those concentrate on
figure out is it possible i actually
dick feynman used to have a term for
that
which was um you know he was always the
you know damn the torpedoes full steam
at full speed ahead
um was kind of like yeah there are all
kinds of problems there are all kinds of
problems but let's just you know
bash forward and try and um and try and
get to the results
um you know not worrying about all these
all these you know attacks that are
coming so to speak
and i think that's um that's kind of how
you how you end up being considered to
have a reality distortion field i mean
maybe
uh it's i think it's something to aspire
to honestly in terms of innovation
leadership
in many ways all right maybe one
one last thing here um the uh
um let's see
um
oh boy
um
well
uh
huh okay there's a comment from i see
here
from a book called faster than thought
from 1953 i think i
think i know that book is about a person
called bowdoin or something
um i think it's a book about um it's an
early book about computers
in which it's still in the phase where
people were talking about computers as
giant electronic brains and so on
um but i see says there's a
there's a quote here from leibniz
um yeah i i've heard this quote before
i'm not
certain it's a correct leibniz quote um
that's unworthy of excellent men to lose
hours like slaves in the labor of
calculation which could safely be
relegated
to anyone else if machines were used
well it's interesting i i don't know i
mean leibniz
so uh
there were human calculators at
different times in history
i mean famously in the manhattan project
uh dick feynman was responsible for
for running the group of human
calculators for
for the manhattan project um and it was
uh that was
people using mechanical calculators to
um uh
because there weren't computers yet um
to do calculations needed for
for um development of of nuclear weapons
um but um uh the thing that um
i don't recall hearing about
um sort of rooms i mean
there were clerks who used mechanical
calculators and mechanical calculators
became pretty widespread by the 1800s
and i'm sure that there were in banks
i'm sure there were rooms full of people
who were just sort of there was the
calculation room so to speak where
people were just
operating these mechanical calculators i
know that um uh
i mean in in when ramanujan worked for
what the port of madras or something
he was uh you know his job was to be a
human calculator primarily
and um and he was really good at that
which is how he came to do all the
experimental mathematics he came to do
but it was kind of a bad use of his
skills to do
um uh probably to do the calculations
for the port of madras
but um the um in any case i think that
um in leibniz's time interesting
question i mean leibniz himself
so so the history of this was was that
mechanical calculators we didn't know
they'd
when they were first invented the
anti-antikythera device
from around first century bc to first
century ad
is the one piece of evidence we have
from antiquity of a kind of gear-based
calculational device
that was primarily used we now can tell
for kind of astronomical orally type
calculations
we don't know how common those things
were in antiquity only one has been
found in this one
particular shipwreck that was
particularly well preserved off this
island off the coast of greece
and where a bunch of famous artifacts
were found including as
turned out sort of accidentally
discovered years later
this this mechanical calculator but in
more modern times
it wasn't until there's a chap called
chicad i think who was a friend of
kepler's
who developed a a sort of a a a
gear-based mechanical calculator
in let's see around the 1630s maybe
um but that device that it's mentioned
in letters with kepler i think
but that device was made of wood and
it's it's long disappeared
but then pascal 1640-ish
blaise pascal made a mechanical
calculator
um that is uh you know made with gear
wheels and so on
um that's an addition calculator and
that calculator exists i've even seen it
it's in a museum in paris
um it's made of brass a rather elegantly
turned out device
but so so that was sort of a thing by
that time and these calculators didn't
work very well they were kind of novelty
items i think
their mechanics weren't that good and so
on leibniz
tried to develop a sort of more like a
four function calculator
and he did that starting where i would
say around the
1670s 1680s um
and for 30 years he worked on the
development of this calculator
and it's really charming you know i
found in his archive essentially this
marketing material for the calculator
about how you know this will be produced
and it will be um but but he had all
kinds of problems with the
with the actual production of this thing
made of brass the thing exists in his
archive
um it's uh you know you can you can see
it it's a
it's a it's an object made of brass um
it's not completely clear it ever worked
properly
um it's not completely clear that it
dealt with carrying bits which is a
difficult thing mechanically because you
might have to propagate this mechanical
force associated with turning gear
wheels
sort of many wheels down the line so to
speak um but anyway
leibniz was quite into that but i don't
recall you know it could have been the
case
that somebody like leidnitz would have a
team of calculators human calculators
um sort of doing calculations for him
and i don't recall ever hearing about
that
process being done um
until very much more modern times um i
think you know leibniz himself was a was
a courtier
and a sort of a a um a person who um
uh would go and do you know he would
study
uh you know he worked for a bunch of
dukes
in hanover and so on and um he uh
uh he would go and they would say you
know i want to prove
that i can marry this particular person
because they have the right
you know genealogy or whatever um and he
would go and do the research and and
figure out that yes that was really true
um and um uh he um
he actually did quite a lot of his
mathematical work he was sort of
stimulated by
by time he spent in paris kind of as a
diplomat ambassador type person
um uh in in the service of his kind of
courtier
activities but but i don't think um
uh this this idea that that's implied in
that quote
of you know you could get sort of uh
less skilled labor
to do calculation if only it could be
done by machine i don't know
maybe leibniz i i'm not aware i mean
certainly i don't think he actualized
any of that
um and i think you know you find his
correspondence where he is trying to
you know he would have liked to build
wolfman alpha 300 years earlier than
than
we got around to building it um and he
kind of had the idea
of um uh not only building sort of the
machinery for calculation
but also collecting the information that
will be needed to do that
and he was in to kind of let us create
great libraries
that will collect information about all
these different kinds of things
that was kind of the best um best effort
to do that i mean there are
very curious stories there was one one
that i rather
find rather interesting a thing called
the much later in history in the
1930s to 1940s i think
a thing called the mundane which was a
an attempt to build the world from alpha
basically
where the queries would come in by
telegraph and they would be
responded to by a team of people who
will be looking up answers on index
cards
and this was an effort um that was done
by some people in belgium
um i'm thinking between world war one
and world war ii
actually so maybe the 1920s to 1930s
and um and this idea was to sort of
collect the knowledge of the world on
index cards
and interact with people through
telegram through a telegraph and they
would get some number of queries per day
you know we're always worried about how
many qps queries per second do we get
and you know will the servers sustain
such and such a number of qps's and
so on they were worried about you know
would they be able to have the right
staff to get these queries by telegraph
and there was a big effort to to um uh
to sort of
make this giant collection of index
cards there are pictures of these rooms
full of kind of
index cards um that contain this
information unfortunately i think the
the whole project was kind of scrapped
it was a project that was also
i think kind of wound up with various
kinds of
world unity world peace type projects
and um
um it it it was
eventually the funding for it
disappeared and the whole project um
decayed but it was sort of an
interesting moment of kind of this
idea of let's collect something i don't
know maybe it was a bit like wikipedia
more probably more like wolfman alpha
because it was really ask a specific
question get an answer
sort of the ultimate reference librarian
type story
centralized for the world so to speak
and communicating
through telegraph lines um which uh why
not
in in those days um uh we didn't have
the internet so to speak
all right well i should wrap up here um
and uh uh actually i have to do another
live stream that's part of my day job
um real soon but um
uh thank you for joining us i i think
that um
um it's very difficult for me to know
when when people ask about um
a sort of recent history it's it's it's
um it's quite challenging to um
um uh
to know what i what i consider
appropriate to say and not and i
i've been having the struggle because i
have a lot of interesting archival
material
that i've collected of interactions with
well lots of lots of people in
science and technology that i've
interacted with and i'm kind of
struggling for the right principles
about uh uh you know
what uh what to put out on the web and
what not to
and i i feel that it's a there's a
certain i mean when
when i'm talking about myself and it's
things i've done i
kind of i'm you know i i can make the
decision for myself about about um
what to say but when i'm talking about
other people i think it's a little bit
more challenging
um even though sometimes the uh
the kind of the insights one might have
uh might be of interest
i think it's some uh you know i'm
um i mean i can reflect back to the
question that was asked earlier about
for example aaron schwartz where there
are
things i could say but they're things
that i'm not sure are um
uh they might be interesting insights
but i don't think they're
sort of appropriate for a public forum
at this time
all right well thanks very much and um
i think the rhythm of these things uh
boy maybe i will have told all the
historical stories i know
soon i'm not sure i don't know how many
of them i really know
um but uh until until that seems to have
happened
i will be doing these q and a's every
two weeks and in the alternating weeks
i will be doing a q a about business and
innovation
so thanks for joining me and